أفضل الحواسيب العملاقة الكلاسيكية لدينا تزداد قوةً يوماً بعد يوم،
وأصبحنا أفضل في الحوسبة، بما في ذلك محاكاة الأنظمة.
لكن محاكاة الطبيعة بشكل عام مشكلة صعبة جداً.
اسمي Victoria Lipinska، واليوم سنستكشف معاً أحد الخوارزميات
التي قد تجعل محاكاة الطبيعة ممكنة على حاسوب كمي.
لنبدأ بمثال ونتناول الكافيين.
هو جزيء بسيط.
لتمثيل التهيئة الطاقية لجزيء كافيين واحد فقط،
سنحتاج تقريباً إلى عشرة أس 48 بت.
يعني عشرة مع 48 صفراً
وهذا يعادل حوالي 10% من عدد الذرات في كوكب الأرض.
والأمر يزداد سوءاً في الواقع.
لو كان عندك 125 مساراً وأردت تخزين جميع التهيئات الممكنة،
ستحتاج ذاكرة أكبر
في حاسوبك الكلاسيكي من عدد الذرات في الكون بأكمله.
هذا مستحيل تمثيله حتى مع الحواسيب العملاقة.
لكن الحواسيب الكمية تبقى مصدر أمل،
لأنها بطبيعتها بارعة في محاكاة الطبيعة.
بالنسبة لجزيء الكافيين، هذا يعني تمثيل
النظام باستخدام 160 qubit.
يبدو هذا أكثر قابلية للتعامل معه.
تم اقتراح خوارزميات كمية متعددة تتيح
للحواسيب الكمية الأصغر محاكاة الطبيعة بشكل إرشادي.
وهنا يأتي دور محلل القيم الذاتية الكمي التغايري، أو VQE.
VQE هي خوارزمية تعمل جزئياً على حاسوب كمي
وجزئياً على حاسوب كلاسيكي.
تتيح لنا إيجاد القيم التي تحل مسألة تحسين معينة.
VQE مرتبطة ارتباطاً وثيقاً بطرق أخرى تتضمن
تغاير المعاملات، كخوارزمية التحسين الكمي التقريبي.
تحديد تطبيقات VQE في مجال عملك أو بحثك
نوع من الفن، لكن هناك إرشادات عامة.
بشكل عام، VQE تنطبق على المسائل التي يمكن صياغتها
كمسألة تحسين بمتغيرات مستمرة.
هذا هو الحال مثلاً في كثير من الكيمياء الكمية.
في الكيمياء غالباً، نهتم بالحالة الأساسية.
الحالة الأساسية هي الحالة ذات أدنى طاقة في النظام.
لإيجاد طاقة الحالة الأساسية، تستكشف VQE
الطاقة لتهيئات مختلفة من النظام
وتبحث عن التهيئة ذات الطاقة الأدنى.
على المستوى العالي، VQE تأخذ وصفاً للنظام الكمي
وتبحث عن أدنى طاقة.
تفعل ذلك بتغيير تهيئة النظام.
للبداية، علينا إدخال وصف مناسب للنظام
يفهمه الحاسوب الكمي ومجموعة معاملات تصفه
وستُحسَّن لاحقاً.
الجزء الكمي من
الخوارزمية يُعِدّ النظام في حالة معينة
يصفها مجموعة معاملات محددة ويحسب الطاقة.
بينما الجزء الكلاسيكي مسؤول
عن تحسين تلك المعاملات في كل خطوة.
هذه العملية الكمية الكلاسيكية تتكرر
حتى نصل إلى أدنى طاقة.
دعنا الآن نتعمق في ما يجري خلف الكواليس.
تهيئة الطاقة تُوصف عادةً في الهاميلتوني
وهو في الغالب مصفوفة كبيرة جداً.
في الجبر، لإيجاد أصغر قيمة ذاتية للمصفوفة
المقابلة لأدنى طاقة في النظام،
كنا ببساطة نجري تحليل القيم الأحادية.
لكن المصفوفات التي سنتعامل معها ضخمة بشكل أسي
وإجراء هذا جبرياً مسألة صعبة بشكل أسي.
هذا الهاميلتوني يجب تمثيله بصيغة
يستطيع الحاسوب الكمي فهمها.
يعني ترجمته من لغة الكيمياء إلى لغة الحوسبة الكمية.
لا تقلق بشأن التفاصيل.
في نهاية المطاف، هناك طرق قابلة للبرمجة لترجمة الهاميلتوني المعتاد
في الكيمياء إلى هاميلتوني يفهمه الحاسوب الكمي.
ثم ندخل هذا
الهاميلتوني مع circuit نسميها الشكل التغايري.
اختيار الشكل التغايري نوع من الفن.
ومجدداً،
هو يمثل أفضل تخميناتنا حول ما قد تكون عليه الحالة الكمية للنظام.
هذا circuit التغايري مُعَلمَن بمجموعة معاملات تيتا،
ونُدخل أيضاً اختياراً أولياً لهذه المعاملات.
بناءً على هذا، الجزء الكمي من VQE:
يُعِدّ الحالة المرجعية، مثلاً حالة الصفر؛
يستخدم circuit كمياً مُعَلمَناً، وهو الشكل التغايري، لتحضير حالة كمية
لتخمين أولي للمعاملات على الحاسوب الكمي؛ ويُقدِّر
الطاقة المقابلة للحالة المُقيَّمة عبر الهاميلتوني.
تقدير الطاقة هذا يُمرَّر بعدها
إلى المحسِّن الكلاسيكي، الذي يجد مجموعة جديدة من المعاملات.
المعاملات تعود من جديد إلى المُحلِّل الكمي،
وتتكرر العملية بأكملها.
الحاسوب الكمي يجد تقديراً جديداً للطاقة،
والمحسِّن الكلاسيكي يجد مجموعة جديدة من المعاملات وهكذا دواليك.
نكرر هذه العملية حتى يتقارب الحل.
يعني حتى يصبح الفرق في النتائج بين الخطوات صغيراً بما يكفي
لاحتياجاتنا.
في النهاية، الخوارزمية تُعيد تلك الطاقة الدنيا.
حسناً، هذا رائع.
لكن ربما تتساءل كيف نعرف أن هذا يعمل فعلاً
وأننا لن نجد عن طريق الخطأ طاقة أدنى مما نبحث عنه؟
سؤال ممتاز.
تبيّن أننا لا نستطيع أبداً تقدير طاقة أدنى.
هذا بفضل ما نسميه مبدأ التغاير.
مبدأ التغاير ينص على أن أكبر حد أدنى
لطاقة النظام هو دائماً
أدنى طاقة مقابلة لتلك الحالة الأساسية.
هذا يعني أن الطاقة المُقيَّمة لأي حالة أخرى في النظام
ستكون دائماً أكبر من أدنى طاقة.
لذلك، مع VQE لن نحصل أبداً على قيمة
أدنى من طاقة الحالة الأساسية.
لكن يمكننا فعلاً أن نتقارب نحو قيمة
أكبر من الحد الأدنى الذي نبحث عنه.
هذا يُسمَّى في أغلب الأحيان حلاً شبه مستقر
وهو تحدٍّ يسعى الباحثون لحله يومياً.
VQE مفيدة لأنها تستخدم circuits أكثر ضحالة
مقارنة بالبروتوكولات الأخرى التي تتيح لنا تقدير طاقة الحالة الأساسية.
هذا يجعلها مناسبة للأجهزة الكمية قريبة المدى.
في هذا الفيديو، ألقينا نظرة خاطفة على ما تستطيع VQE فعله وكيف بُنيت.
لكني أشجعك على استكشاف Qiskit في هذا السياق.
حتى لو كنا ما زلنا في بداية رحلتنا الكمية،
ربما تجده مفيداً بالفعل للمسائل التي تحاول حلها.
اسمي Victoria Lipinska وهذه كانت نظرة عامة
على خوارزمية محلل القيم الذاتية الكمي التغايري.